she's a senior researcher at Microsoft
research in Redmond and she's going to
tell us about her work on diversity
maximization in the offline and
proposable core set models
thank you
um hi everyone thanks for coming so
today I'm going to start by giving you
some backgrounds on diversity and
maximization problem and its
applications in practice then I'll tell
you about composable courses and its
application in other theoretical models
of computations for big data and for the
technical part of the talk I'm going to
talk about our composable course as
results for pseudo Forest it's a joint
work with xiamenaryana and finally I'll
mention some generalization of the
problem to the constrained version of
the problem and tell you about some
experimental results that we have with
my co-author story on trayanovsky at
Microsoft
okay so let's see what diversity
maximization problem is we're given a
set of endpoints in some Metric space
and a parameter K the goal is to pick a
subset of size K of these points with
maximum diversity
okay so for some notion of diversity
that we will talk about later
okay so why do we care about this
problem this problem comes a lot in for
example summarization let's say you have
a user and you want to populate a feed
for that user so there are a set of
messages that from that a friend friends
of that user or from the channels that
are posted in channels that the user is
part of and you want to basically show a
summary of those messages to the user
and now in your summary you want to you
don't want to have repeated messages you
want to have some A diversity and uh in
what you're using showing to the user it
also has like in general it has
application for video summarization uh
like a set of images documents and so on
okay so it has application for example
in search where you want to make sure
that the results of your search is
diverse
um in a recommendation system let's say
a user is buying some product and you
want to recommend few other options to
look at or even like for candidates you
want to suggest a few candidates to look
at and you want to have some kind of
diversity on in what you're suggesting
to the user
okay and um in many other applications
this diversity maximization problem
comes up so
um usually in these applications the
objects that you have are mapped into
points in a high dimensional space or
some other metric space and now as input
we are given these points set of points
in some Metric space and let's see what
do we mean now by the notion of
diversity so what does it mean to pick a
subset of diverse points
okay so um in actually 2001 genre
holderson like introduced this taxonomy
of diversity based measures the
diversity measures that are based on
pairwise distances between the points so
I'll go over uh go over some of them to
just see like for example what's our
typical measures that people use in
practice for diversity measures for
example I could be I could
um so the first one is basically minimum
Paradise distance which means that
maximizing this notion means that I want
to pick a subset of size K such that no
two of them are very close so I want to
maximize the minimum pairwise distance
between the set of points that I've
picked okay for example if this this is
the set of points that I have and the
um orange ones are the ones that I
picked on them diversity between the set
of points that I've picked is basically
the distance between the two closest one
okay so if I pick these three points
instead then the diversity is lower
because there are two points now that
are closer to each other
we have any questions
okay so uh it's known that a greedy
algorithm would give you a constant
Factor approximation for this problem so
people also consider some of paradise
distances notion of diversity which is
basically a more robust notion for
diversity it basically counts uh
computes the distances between any pair
of points and sum them up so this will
be what we measure as the diversity of a
set of points for example for these
three points uh the sum of these three
arrows is what we measure as their
diversity if you pick these three points
then we have again a lower diversity
and again for this problem it's known
that the local social algorithm would
give you a constant Factor approximation
and
um so another notion which is basically
an interpolation between these two
measures is basically the sum of
distances to nearest neighbors so it's
not as fragile as the first one which
only depends on two two points but it's
also taking into account the minimum
distances so you sum over all the points
that you have picked their distance to
their nearest neighbors so for example
for this guy this is the closest
distance for this one this is the
closest one and vice versa okay so this
is what you measure as a diversity of a
set of points if you pick these three
points instead then this is like what
you measure as their diversity
um so again this is like an
interpolation between the first two
measures uh first uh in 2001 Chandra and
holderson gave a low key factor
approximation for the problem uh later
in 2016 bhaskara tadiri mirochti and
Svenson like improved the approximation
factor to a constant using NLP
um okay
um so there are like other measures for
example what is the cost of the minimum
perfect matching among the points that
you have picked so this is also one
other notion that people use for a
diversity of a set of points and
basically yes for these four points for
example this will be what we measure as
their diversity if you pick these four
points then the diversity is lower
um again like genre and halderstone gave
order Locke approximation for this
problem and this was basically the best
known uh approximation for the problem
so far
okay so again like there are all these
other Notions like what is the cost of
the minimum spanning tree like a minimum
tsp star and so on
okay and basically this was uh what we
knew about these problems and I also
want to show to mention that this is
basically the
um all the measures that are based on
pairwise distances there are also like
some other measures that are not
necessarily based on pairwise distances
for example one of them is this a volume
where basically given a set of endpoints
the goal is to pick a subset of size K
such that the volume of the parallel
pipette spanned by those by those K
points is maximized
I won't have time to go over all of them
but that greedy algorithm particle I'm
going to mention
great
um okay again for this problem this is
much harder you cannot get better than
some exponential Factor approximation
for the problem but Nikola showed that
how we can actually achieve like uh e to
the K over to approximation for the
problem okay and again this is a higher
order notion of diversity because it
doesn't only depend on pairwise
distances between the points for example
if the points are linearly dependence
then you get zero
um otherwise like it will be non-zero
um okay so uh in a recent work we
actually uh close up uh the gap for the
matching problem so for the only
remaining one here uh so we improved the
locker approximation to a constant
Factor approximation
okay so with that let me
um move on to the composable corset
setting which is basically uh a notion
which is used for many of the massive
data models of computation so let's see
what a composable corsets are
um so in particular because many of the
applications for diversity maximization
need to handle large amounts of data for
example summarization searching and so
on and there has been a lot of effort
that goes into solving these problems in
massive data models of computation and
that's why we're looking at this notion
of composable courses
um which is a powerful tool that at the
same time gives you an algorithm in many
other models of models or computation
that concerns massive data for example
distributed streaming it
okay so let's see what courses are a
corset of a data set is a small subset
of it that represents the data very well
okay so
um what do we mean it means that suppose
that I have a data set and I want to
solve the problem over that data set
then a corset is just a small subset of
it such as solving the problem or the
corset gives me a good approximation for
solving the problem over the whole data
okay so it's very it's basically task
specific so if you are you can think of
it as you're given like a sum function
that you want to optimize on your
original points that if optimizing F on
this subset gives you some let's say
Alpha Factor approximation then we say
that we have an alpha Factor coordinate
right so this is basically a generic
notion here we are looking at the notion
of composable corsets which is basically
a corset with composability property
meaning that the union of multiple
corsets should be a corset for the union
of the whole data
okay so what do we mean suppose that I
have multiple Point sets V1 V2 to VM and
we want to come up with subsets U1 U2 to
um such that if I check the courses and
take their Union basically the value of
this function f over the union of the
course that's approximates the value of
the function f over the union of the
whole data let's say by this
approximation Factor Alpha
okay so if I have this property I say
that I have like an alpha composable
corset
no it doesn't so what we are looking at
is basically what is the summarization
algorithm so at the time that we are
creating this course like we don't know
how many other data stuff there will be
and what will be those data sets so yeah
okay so now let's see why we care about
this notion and how do they employ
algorithms in other in other models of
computation
um like a trivial application would be
distributed for example MPC model
um where your data is partitioned let's
say over machine that your data is very
large it's partition over machine so
what if you know how to compute the
compostable corset basically each
machine can compute a composable corset
only on its own data and send it to a
single aggregator okay because the size
of the corsets is small the total
communication is low and because of the
composibility property the solution
computed by the aggregator is a good
approximation for the whole data
so let's see the application in the
streaming setting so in the streaming
model of computation you're receiving an
a set of elements on the like in a
stream and you actually want to compute
a solution on the Fly using a small
storage right so basically if you have a
corset for
um the problem that you want to solve
basically you can reduce this the space
usage of the algorithm from n down to
square root type how can you do it
basically you can just divide your
stream of inputs into chunks of size
square root 10 and now
um you can start receiving the elements
of the first chunk until you receive all
of them completely you store them in the
memory and once you receive the whole
chunk you just compute a corset and then
ignore the rest but only the course so
you only keep the points that are in the
course and then you Mo you move on to
the second chunk you wait until you
receive the whole Channel completely at
the end you compute the corset and
ignore the rest okay until the end of
the stream uh where at the end you just
compute the solution of your problem to
the union of these courses again because
of the composability property this is
going to be a good solution and this
allows for the space usage of the
algorithm to go down from n to roughly
square roots and assuming the size of
the courses is small
okay
um basically you can apply the same
framework for like partially Dynamic
algorithms basically in the incremental
model right so once you receive one
element
um you can just if the if this is
basically if this uh completes the one
chunk of your data you just compute a
corset and keep the corset basically and
once you're given a query you can just
compute the solution and the union of
the current chunk and all the corsets
that you previously computed
okay so again this allows for the size
of the instance to go down from n to
roughly square root
okay
um so they're not very good with
deletions but there's this notion of
robust courses that allow us to handle
like uh up to L let's say
outliers which are basically the points
that we are going to delete later on and
uh by adding an extra factor of f
and in general like courses has been
used to basically generally to improve
the runtime of algorithms using this
partition and solve method in the
context of similarity search and so on
okay so let's see what um so we uh We've
looked at this problem from the
perspective of uh corsets as well
um and basically uh it was known how we
can get like constant Factor
approximation for these problems and or
the lock K uh factor for these two and
uh for the volume maximization it's
known basically how to get an order K to
the K approximation and it's known as
basically it's typed okay so note that
the size of the corset is roughly K so
it doesn't depend on on the original
number of points so no matter what is
the original size of the point that you
can always scale it down to K
while preserving the important
information
and in our recent work we basically show
that you can also get a constant Factor
approximation with the courses of size k
for the matching problem and also uh
like a corset of size K to the one plus
Epsilon with approximation factor of 1
over Epsilon
and this is basically the result that
I'm going to talk about
[Music]
any questions
is it often the case that if you have
multiple corsets you can take a computer
courses out of that to reduce the size
um if you have two courses you would
have like size you can you can normally
apply in a recursive way but each time
you're losing some Factor each time
okay
um so what what we do here is that we
I'm going to show you how we can compute
a composable corsets for the uh some of
the nearest neighbor notion of diversity
again it's a joint work with shamner
notary or not
uh and the statement is as follows so
there exist a composable courses of size
K to the one plus Epsilon with
approximation factor of 1 over Epsilon
for the sum of nearest neighbor notion
of diversity that is basically for a
subset of size K we Define its diversity
to be the sum over all the elements in
that subset its distance to the nearest
other points that we have picked in that
subset okay so just to remind you this
is the notion that we are looking at
okay just a reminder
um okay and again we are in the
composable corset settings meaning that
I just want to compute uh I want to come
up with a summarization algorithm that
given a point that can summarize it for
me so that later on we have this
composability property
okay so first I'm going to tell you
about the greedy algorithm which is
basically a common algorithm used in
this context a lot
um and then all this will then I'll show
a simple algorithm that gives me a
corset of size K squared and then I'll
tell you how we can improve it to K to
the 1.5 I'll not mention how to uh
improve it to K to the OnePlus Epsilon
but uh
um hopefully I can say some idea about
it okay so what is the greedy algorithm
so given a set of points the greedy
algorithm goes for K iterations and each
iteration picks the points whose minimum
distance to all the points that you have
already picked is maximized okay so for
example it's uh first choose some
arbitrary Point C1
and then it picks the point that is
paired us away from C1 and then at the
third iteration it picks the point whose
minimum distance to C1 and C2 is
maximized
and it continues for k iterations
so now it has like some nice properties
for example if you let R to be the
minimum pairwise distance between the
points that you have picked in this
procedure then what we know is that
everyone else that you have not picked
is within distance R of someone that you
picked okay so pictorially if the
minimum distance between these three
centers that you already picked is are
then
um it's basically easy to check that
everyone else is within distance R of
someone that you have picked otherwise
in the last iteration you could you
should have picked someone else
and so what does it mean it means that
basically I can cluster all the points
into K clusters in a way that's the the
distances within each cluster by
triangle inequality is at most to R
okay so now let's see how using this we
can get a simple corset for uh of size K
Square okay so the corset algorithm is
going to be very simple it's as follows
we just run the greedy algorithm and it
gives us this set of K clusters from
each cluster I'm going to PK points K
ib-3 points that also includes the
centers okay so I run this algorithm I
first pick the centers and put them in
my corset and then I'll pick K minus one
other arbitrary points from each cluster
and also put them in the corset
so it's trivial that the size of this
course is K squared because you have K
clusters and you're picking K points and
now why is does it actually give you a
corset you need to say that basically
for any optimal solution you can replace
that with someone from the courses such
as the overall diversity does not
decrease as much
uh so um so here there are two cases the
so the first case is the if the optimal
solution itself the value of the
diversity for the optimal solution
itself is smaller than 5 KR then we
argue that basically the centers
themselves that we put in the course
that have large diversity okay why is
that because basically for each point in
the uh each point of the center that we
picked there uh because the minimum
pairwise distance between the centers is
are there additionals of everyone to
their closest neighbor is also at least
R okay so basically we are summing over
all the points uh in the among the
centers their distance to the nearest
neighbor so it's going to be as his R
times K so this will give us like a 5kr
approximation
so the other case is basically when the
value of the optimal solution is at
least five times K times R but basically
in this case it's okay to move any one
from the optimal solution to someone
within distance to R because this way
the distance between any pair of points
only in the optimal solution only
changes by
um four times R so the total value of
the diversity diversity function only
decreases by uh
um four times K times R but because the
optimal solution has value five times K
times R is going to give us like a
factor five approximation
um so so now what we will do is that we
are we will look at the points in the
optimal solution and we are going to
replace and anyway like if the rki
points in cluster I we're going to
replace those KR points from the optimal
solution with an arbitrary set of Ki
points from the Corsa okay so
pictorially and the green points here
are the optimal solution and the red
points here are the points from the core
side that we computed so what we do is
that
um we are going to replace any point
from the course from the optimal
solution it's not one from the corset
um and basically by what we just argued
like the diversity of this set of points
is going to be roughly the same as the
diversity of the points
um in the optimal solution
exactly yeah exactly yeah
um
how can you ensure that there are at
least okay notes in each cluster
and so this is how we picked our
um
algorithm so we included so in in the
corsets we first run this uh greedy
algorithm and from each cluster we
included K points in the corset so
you just include all the points well
then even in the optimal solution there
can't be uh
so these are a good points
um
okay so now let's see how we can improve
this corset size
um
um as you just mentioned like why do we
really need to keep K points from each
of these clusters right so in particular
uh so so the reason we might need them
is that maybe we want to match uh there
are more than one more than one point in
the optimal solution that we want to
match with and we don't have enough of
them if you just pick like a single
point or a constant number of points so
let's take a a closer look basically
another two kinds of Optimal Solutions
there are these points in the optimal
solution that are in clusters which at
most uh which uh there is at most one
point from the optimal solution let me
call them opt one so there's only a
single optimal solution in this cluster
and under this Ops greater than two
which are basically the subset of the
Optimal Solutions that are in the
Clusters which there are more than one
point from the Optimal Solutions
so they're pictured here
um some examples
okay and a simple observation is that
basically the points that are in the
second group of greater than two it does
not contribute much to the value of the
objective function so the because
there's another point from the optimal
solution there their distance to the Min
to the nearest uh point is at most two R
so they're not contributing more than
two R to our objective functions so we
can basically more or less like we can
roughly ignore them okay so we can move
them anywhere as else as long as they're
not ruining the contribution of the
points that are in uh the thing these
optim one
right so if if I move someone from here
to someone close by here I'm also uh
um ruining the contribution of this
point which I don't want to do
so would you call these things the
Clusters the C1 c2c3 they're well
separate from as well but in principles
I'm basically connecting everyone to
their closest neighbor
yeah
so each point is closer to the closest
okay uh so now suppose that
hypothetically I had some points in my
corsets somewhere very far from the
Optimal Solutions
okay so then
um and no no point from the optimal
solution is therefore here so what I can
do is that I can just uh pick uh uh one
Center uh one point from each cluster
and I'm going to match as much as I can
inside the Clusters and move all the
excess points there okay so K is a
subset that is a set of points in my
core set of size at least K so I can
move everyone that is excess over there
so it does not like ruin the
contribution of for example C2
um and um so the problem with this so
this is all good so basically now I
replace these points in the optimal
solution with these guys so the
diversity does not decrease so the only
points uh so the only negative part is
that basically such as that s may not
exist
so what instead I'm going to do is that
I'm going to use the power of uh two
sets of Four Points so in particular
it's only enough to keep K points from
either C1 and C2
okay and the algorithm would be just as
follows just run the greedy algorithm
keep the center of all the Clusters plus
also keep K points from C1 and K points
from C2
okay instead of picking K points from
each of them
and basically why why does it work uh
basically the distance of C1 and C2 is
roughly the diameter okay okay so now uh
what we can argue is that we can now
move all the excess excess points to all
of them either to S to C1 or C2 okay
and I'm going to choose this uh
uniformly at random with probability a
half so now the contribution of everyone
else is preserved with probability so a
half half of the contribution of each
point is preserved with probability a
half okay so again pictorially so this
is C1 and C2 the distance is roughly the
diameter now for any other point in the
optimal solution it's distance to either
C2 is larger than the diameter or the
distance to see what is larger than the
diameter so because we are picking one
of these two with probability a half we
are preserving half of its contribution
with uh probability of so either C1 or
C2 is going to be a good option for us
so these are the first two clusters
right so you run the greedy algorithm it
gives you a set of centers and now you
look at all the points that are closer
closer their closest Center is C1 and
their code Center is
okay
um okay and we also know that the
contribution of the optimal solution
cannot be larger than the diameter so
this gives us a constant Factor
approximation
um okay so there's another problem with
this and the main problem is that
basically C1 and C2 themselves may not
have enough points so they may have much
less than K points okay and then how do
you want to proceed basically do you
want to
um do you want to continue with C3 C4
and so on and it's not clear like if
that will work so what we will do
instead is the following we will
basically show so this will be our goal
from now on so
um so you can forget about everything
else so here is a problem so you're
given a set of endpoints in some Metric
space and you want to find two subsets
each of size K such that their distance
is maximized
okay
so the problem is clear so we're given a
sort of endpoints the goal is to find
two sets each of size K such that their
distance is maximized how do you do it
okay and basically the reason why this
is enough is that
um again we can argue that we can move
all the excess points to either s and t
shows and uniformly at random and one of
those options will work for us
okay the same reasoning as before
um so let's focus on this and let's see
how how do we find it and in fact what
would be this uh what will be the
maximum distance between two sets s and
t
okay so it turns out that basically if
you define our hats to be a radius of
the smallest ball that contains at least
n minus K plus 1 points
then this is basically the distance that
you're looking for so there exists sets
s and t such that their distance is
approximately our hat
okay in fact it's like easy to show that
you can't get better than that but uh
also but it's not clear like if that
that value is possible to achieve and
um here is uh what we should basically
so let's see how we can find two sets
SNT each of size case such as their
distance is roughly our head
okay
um so here are a few cases so first of
all we assume that the total number of
points is at least K to the 1.5 2 times
K to the one for 0.5 know that if this
is not the case we can we can put
everyone in the corset and that will be
all good
um so the first case is the following
basically the first case is where there
exists a point x such that within the
ball of radius our head over two of it
there exists K points
okay so why why we are good in this case
is that basically we know that
um uh outside of the ball of radius our
heads around X there exists at least K
points otherwise this would contradict
the definition of our head we would have
found a smaller ball okay so now there
are K points inside their K points
outside I'm going to let the inner
points to be S and the outer points to
be T I know that the distances at least
R hat over two
what was the contradiction
because like your R hat is for n minus K
plus one points
and so yeah yes so if basically if there
are uh if there are not enough uh points
outside then you would have found a
smaller ball
is it
is
or is it inside
like the definition of R hat
that you have at the top no this n minus
K plus one uh oh yes so this is inside
but this would also mean that there are
K points outside
yeah the reason I Define it this way is
because of the point on the boundary
okay
um okay so otherwise where in this case
where basically for
um each point x in my op in in my data
set the ball of radius are had over two
around it contains less than K points
okay so now there are two cases here uh
so the first uh like the first case is
that basically when the majority of the
points have at least square roots a k
number of points around them within the
ball of radius R hat over four uh so why
why we are good in this case so let me
move the picture up there
um so in this case what I'm what I can
do is that I'm going to uh randomly
sample square root K of these centers
and now in the set s I'm going to put
those uh and those centers plus everyone
that is within the cells are head over
four
okay so because I assume that there are
at least square root K points within
distance or had over four of most of
them majority of them then I'm going to
get enough points from this sampling so
we will I I'll get at least K points
and uh so now what I'm going to do is
that I'm going to remove everyone that
is within distance our head over two and
um and and basically this means that
um and now I need to argue that
basically there are at least K points
outside of these balls that is remaining
for me that I can choose uh to be in the
set why is that because I only snap at
square root K Points each of them has at
most K points in the ball of radius are
had over two around them so if I just
remove these points because and the
value of n is at 6 K to the one point
two times K to the 1.5 I get that there
exists at least K points outside of this
box
okay so I can just let this set be the
set T so that and I know that the
distance between s and t now is at least
R hat over four
okay now the final case uh the final
case is basically when the majority of
the points have less than square root K
points within distance R had over four
of them
and in this case what I'm going to do is
that I'm going to from that majority I'm
going to choose K of them so I'm going
to pick K of those points and and that
will be my set s so they're K points and
I'm going to remove everyone that is
within distance our head over four of
them so everyone that are in these balls
and uh why again why does there exist
um K points outside of this boss the
reason is that again I had only cables
each of them contained less than square
roots okay points so the total number of
points that I removed is going to be at
most K times the square root K so I get
enough points outside of this box so
again I can pick like a k of them so
this is going to be the set s these are
going to be the set T and the distance
between them again is at least our hat
over four
okay so basically this will give me uh
the result that I want so if the number
of points is at least K to the 1.5 then
we can find SNT with distance roughly R
hat over four and uh one can show that
basically
um one can generalize this idea and to
the case where if the number of points
is larger than K to the 1 plus Epsilon
you can get two sets whose distance is
roughly Epsilon times are
okay so now that we solve this
intermediate problem so let's see how we
get a corset so the corset will be
um as before so if the number of points
is smaller than n to the uh uh is the if
n is smaller than K to the 1 plus
Epsilon we're going to put everyone in
the corset otherwise we can just run the
greedy compute the Clusters include the
centers of the Clusters in the corset
and then using the previous algorithm we
just find S and T and put those sets s
and t also in the course okay so it's
easy to show that this also satisfies
the composibility property so this
course is also composable and so this
will give us a core set of size K to the
one plus Epsilon with approximation
factor of one over Epsilon
okay so this finishes
um this part of the talk so in the last
uh
a few minutes so one basically
um
a question that we think uh should be
doable is basically if we can get a
tight result here like a constant factor
with a corset of size K order k
um okay so in the remaining part of the
talk I'm going to
um briefly mention some generalization
of diversity maximization problem to the
constraint setting and uh so this is
basically a joint work with the story on
sorry yanovsky from Microsoft so let me
tell you about this generalization of
the problem to the constraint setting
okay so we're looking again at the
diversity maximization problem but now
the set of points that we have are
partitioned into some groups okay and
now we have this additional constraint
that from each group in this in our
summary from each group we want to pick
a certain number of points let's say Ki
so the same problem under partition
construct base okay so we are given this
partitioning we also given instead of
giving instead of us being given K we
are given K1 K2 to km so m is the number
of groups and uh we are we want to
satisfy that in our summary we want to
pki points from group I such as the
overall diversity of what we choose is
maximize
for example here uh previously we only
had K which was equal to three so this
is what we would have picked but now
that solution is no more feasible we
want to pick only one points from here
one point from here and two points from
here so this will be maybe the solution
that maximizes diverse overall diversity
also satisfying the constraint
um okay so why do we care about this
problem again for example one
um application of it would be to
incorporate recency of the messages okay
so each method in the feed generation
scenario each user each message comes
with a posting time right so as the
messages gets older we want to include
less of them so the summary we have is
basically we want to incorporate uh
recency in summary that we have so what
we can do is that you can basically
partition the messages into batches
based on their time and then we want to
assign a less budget to the all their
messages
Okay so
uh we want to basically for example the
messages in a month we can partition
them into four weeks and we want to have
more uh messages from the current week
in the summary that we are showing to
the user
okay so let's see what is so this is
known as either Fair diversity
maximization or constraint diversity
maximization and let's see what is known
for the problem for the notion of
minimum pairwise distance
uh momolito basically gave an uh M plus
one approximation for the problem
um for some of pair right distances and
some of the nearest neighbor Notions of
diversity the the algorithms that worked
for diversity maximization also works
for uh under the like partition
constraint setting as well and also one
question here would be if one can get
like a constant Factor approximation uh
for this problem and also if in the
corset setting basically
um
the work of McGregor at all implied a
corset of a constant Factor
approximation with uh
um only order K uh number of points from
each group uh for the sum of paradise
distance notion of diversity there was
like an algorithm that was
um giving like a good one perception on
approximation but the total number of
points in the courses was large it
either depended on N or the aspect ratio
um and so in a recent work we basically
showed how we can
get like a corset that is totally
independent of the initial number of
points so we we're able to improve the
uh size of the Corsa down to KI squared
we also show uh similar results for the
other notion of diversity but here the
approximation Factor again
um it's not tight so the one other open
questions would be if we can get tight
results here
okay so in the last uh slide uh I'll
just mention some experimental results
that we have for this problem uh
basically as we expect we run this
um if you just uh basically the first
experiment says that if you just run
diversity maximization on this set of
messages what you get does not respect
recency but this is what we expect so
there is a need for defining this notion
of uh constant diversity maximization in
order to incorporate for recency of the
summary that you have and the second is
basically computes the price of
balanceness so how much do we lose to by
resorting to the constraint version of
the problem Fair diversity maximization
as opposed to a normal diversity
maximization for some of pairwise
distances the loss is only one percent
for some of nearest neighbor distance so
it's 20 and for minimum pair of distance
is 50 so basically this you you can also
see this interpolation of this notion
between the two in this experiment as
well so basically this minimum Paradise
distance is very fragile so you actually
see a lot of loss in the diversity of a
new resort to the constant version of
the problem
and um and the final set of results
shows the power of courses basically so
using the course that you don't need to
recompute your summary for the past data
you can actually reuse it and by doing
that it allows you to improve the
runtime of the algorithm by a factor of
in practice that's a lot and
um this basically only and and this is
done by only losing on diversity by a
few percent
so um so I'll stop here uh so
um I've marked the open questions here
so if you want I'll be happy to talk
about them yeah thank you for coming
[Applause]
you put questions
yeah uh I was curious where the one over
Epsilon came from then because like you
you didn't quite get to explain that or
what what is the
we need to
repeat the questions sure so
um so the question is basically where
does this one over Epsilon factor in the
approximation comes from
um and the answer is that so I didn't go
into like the result that gets like K to
the one plus Epsilon but basically you
need to have this nested set of uh
points and uh the ratio of each of them
is like uh
uh the ratio the the number of points in
each of them increases by factor of K to
the uh Epsilon and basically the
distance therefore is only one over
absence is just Epsilon times the total
distance of our hat
so you're partitioning it into like some
nested stats the distance between any
two adjacent one is only Epsilon times
the total distance
yeah two questions one is
what is uh I mean we have this metric
measures but what exactly do people care
about when they are trying to read
messages like what what is the diversity
measure you mean
these are proxies for diversity that you
care about so it really depends on the
applications for example like um for
example for the video the summarization
people use a lot this uh DPP and ocean
this volume
um also for like
um yeah I remember but for some
practical work also like uh uh for
summarization of a set of messages as as
well like people try different and uh
like there's a slight preference towards
volume as well
uh but I'm also aware that both of these
minimum pairwise distance and some of
her voice distances is used uh in
applications uh and like the also the
work by pascara miraki and uh
um Swanson argued that there are some
applications for which this uh distance
to the nearest neighbor is what uh
what's best for some applications the
second question is about the choice okay
kind of use K in the
the design of the algorithm of the
construction the whole set
so that it is you know and one take some
of these constructions and
like not rely on K in some nice way or
uh if this game you change or how
sensitive are they to playing a choice
of things
sure yeah the question is basically
whether
um the choice of K is kind of uh strict
or it can change on the algorithm also
can be flexible with respect to that
right
um so some of the algorithms are
flexible you can just continue further
for example the greedy algorithm it will
just be the continuation right but the
local such algorithm you really need to
run it with the new k
on the Practical side
um and there are many applications that
case someone fits for example how many
results do you really want to show
um to the user let's say in the first
page of the search so this is going to
be your okay and if they want to go
further to the next Pages then you have
like further values of paper it's not
something that changes
oh
I'm wondering could you tell us what the
order of one terms
and for which ones for example the
initial is a diversity like the the
basically offline diversity maximization
these are constants less than five the
one we gave
uh here
uh I believe it's like 16.
which might be the largest
yeah
okay
um we'll take any remaining questions
foreign
[Applause]